southwest medical the sponsor of this
next segment is home to many of our
local hospice care heroes rocky spoke to
a doctor about the hospice services they
provide and addresses the questions
people frequently ask
you always have such great information
about hospice care i'm with southwest
medical we're kind of debunking the
myths and also telling the truth about
it so let's just start with you know
what is hospice care let's define it for
people
so hospice care is a level of care
that's really appropriate when patients
have a
life-limiting illness where they there
are no more curative options
and the patient and their family choose
to
embrace the time that they have and
instead of spending that time pursuing a
cure and visiting doctors
they do whatever they want to do and we
support them in that and we bring the
care to their home
on their schedule the question is now
let's get into these frequently asked
questions
is hospice a place that people must go
so hospice is absolutely not a place
hospice is a level of care and service
that people have to be eligible for
and something like 98 of our patients
are cared for in their home or wherever
they were living before hospice started
so if they're in a group home or in
assisted living or
in an apartment wherever they live
there are different levels of care
within hospice so sometimes a patient
may have unmanaged symptoms that qualify
them to go
to an inpatient unit for short-term care
so hospice is never supposed to provide
the place to live and we never make
patients leave their home is hospice
care expensive
so hospice care
is covered by medicare and medicaid and
just about every commercial insurance
so
for most patients there's not medicare
and medicaid there's no copay most
commercial insurances there's no co-pay
hospice is basically free to the patient
and medicare and medicaid pay the
hospice for the care that's provided how
long can someone be in hospice care
so the the criteria for hospice care are
on paper if you will at medicare it says
that an individual will have a prognosis
of six months or fewer so they're not
expected to long to live longer than six
months
we have had patients in hospice care for
four years
hospice
does not put an expiration date on the
patient or the service
we just recertify the patient and we go
out and make sure they're still eligible
for the care
beautiful service and is hospice just
medication is a frequently asked
question
so hospice is not just medication so
hospices are responsible for for
providing all of
the medications
even a little bit related to the
patient's what we call terminal
diagnosis and also all of their
medications that are for comfort so an
antidepressant or pain medicine or
nausea medicine but we also provide and
i would say this is more important than
the medicine we provide the nurses and
the doctors and the social workers and
the chaplains
and a bereavement service so we provide
people
to help the patient and their family
understand what's happening and not be
afraid of it
we want to thank southwest medical for
sponsoring this segment they serve all
across southern nevada and if you want
more information you can call that
number 702-877-5199
or visit their website at smalv.com
we'll be right back